del papel que va a tener ahora la
realeza británica la monarquía británica
con la muerte de la reina es el segundo
y un tema clave que es el papel del
príncipe andrés recordemos el papel del
príncipe andrés quien a quien se le
retiraron los honores militares a
comienzos de año por ese escándalo en
medio del marco de las acusaciones
contra harvey weinstein este magnate de
eeuu como creo ese que particularmente
el caso del papel del príncipe andrew
puede afectar o puede tener en esta
nueva era que se abre en la monarquía
británica
y en primer lugar muchas gracias por la
oportunidad de intervenir en este
programa especial y un poco siguiendo
con lo que comentaba la doctora mena
hace hace unos minutos he escuchado con
mucho interés o intervención pues uno de
los retos con los que se enfrenta el
reino unido- y la mancomunidad es la
sustitución de una figura que nunca en
ningún momento durante su largo reinado
dio lugar
directamente protagonista de ningún tipo
de escándalo en ese sentido
precisamente la doctora mena hablaba del
sucesor del
rey carlos tercero pero evidentemente
pues también es lógico que nos
preguntemos sobre su hermano pequeño el
príncipe andrew en ese sentido yo
personalmente soy optimista creo que
entretener a lo peor
ya ha pasado evidentemente no se va a
olvidar fácilmente aunque también es
cierto que no todo el mundo pues
comparte
este juicio mediático tan duro al que
fue sometido
no olvidemos que en ningún momento se le
dio bajo tocar si que es cierto pues que
llegó a un acuerdo
extrajudicial y ese tipo de acuerdos
siempre son controvertidos por muchos
motivos y uno de ellos es por qué
la mayoría de observadores consideran
que suponen un reconocimiento de culpa
un reconocimiento de que realmente pues
algo había quizá no todos los hechos de
los que se les acusa de los que se le
acusaba pero que alguna cosa habría
hecho si no pues no no habría pagado
pero lo cierto y lo digo también por mi
experiencia como abogado es que la
realidad que hay detrás de este tipo de
acuerdos es mucho más es mucho más
compleja y por tanto hay un porcentaje
de la opinión pública pues que no
necesariamente
comparte estas críticas tan feroces que
hemos escuchado los últimos años y sobre
todo los últimos meses en relación al
príncipe andrew pero bueno también es
cierto que evidentemente que su que su
imagen ha quedado muy dañada y como
usted comentaba efectivamente a
principios de año pues le fueron
retirados los honores militares y la
propia consideración del
miembro de la familia real a efectos de
la mayoría de actos de actos públicos en
ese sentido pues es uno de los muchos
retos no lo único al cual se enfrenta no
solamente el sucesor de elisabeth 2a
sino tan perdón de sabes segunda sino
también
a la propia institución monárquica
británica en su vertiente doméstica y en
su vertiente internacional como cabeza
de la mancomunidad de la comarca como
nos decía yo soy optimista y yo creo que
el reino unido- superará este reto
tal y como históricamente ha superado
otros retos y los está superando porque
no olvidemos que esta sucesión llega en
un momento en que el reino unido no ha
acabado de superar algunos de los retos
de los que se enfrenta en el caso del
break si por ejemplo el pueblo habló el
pueblo decidió recuperar plenamente la
soberanía y abandonar este proto estado
europeo centralizado que se ha ido
tejiendo las últimas décadas sin embargo
esta decisión
no ha sido aceptada
en parte del establishment político
mediático académico que se continúa
mostrando profundamente
partidario de renunciar a esta soberanía
y ser más bien una provincia de la
europea más que un país independiente
tenemos por ejemplo el caso de irlanda
del norte donde claramente pues hay una
interferencia muy clara de la de la
unión europea en un intento de dividir
al reino al reino unido por tanto no es
el único reto al que se enfrenta el
reino unido pero como lo decía y yo soy
optimista y confío en que hace unos años
cuando miramos atrás pues podremos decir
que el país lo ha superado y la
mancomunidad la commonwealth también lo
ha superado